[Music]
let's go to dalton in austin hey dalton
what's up dude
hi dr john how are you i'm good brother
what's up
well not much um
so my wife and i are starting to
miscommunicate more
and i want to know how do i take steps
to improve our conversations and
end the unnecessary fighting or maybe
better than why is it happening
tell me more about it how long you all
been married
uh almost a year we're coming up on our
one year anniversary okay
um
what are y'all fighting about
well
i i would say they're big fights over
very little things like incredibly
nuanced inconsequential
non-important
things
i would say this never used to happen in
all the two and a half years that we
dated
um
man none of that matters anymore
yeah yeah i know i know yeah totally
argue
yeah we argue over the little thing
itself and then we argue about how we
just argued trying to decide what went
wrong and where there was a
miscommunication and trying to solve the
problem
and it just leads to a lot of hurt
feelings in the end because
someone has to be right someone must be
wrong
and my concern is that these have been
increasing in number in the last month
and so when i asked my wife when she
thinks they started she told me i've
been doing something
maybe wrong or insensitive or situation
worthy that could lead to the situation
almost every other day for the last
seven months and that she's only just
recently started bringing it to light or
she ignores it or brushes it off
normally
and that scares the heck out of me
because
i don't want to be
consistently putting my wife in a
situation where
you know she feels on edge or where we
are about to fight and i just don't know
it you know it's it's like i've created
an unsafe
environment for her well maybe maybe
maybe um
maybe what's the things what is she
saying that you do that creates an
unsafe environment
well she hasn't said those words exactly
that's me
being concerned okay i can give an
example of a little thing give me an
example what's the thing that she said
you've been doing for seven months that
makes it
um
that drives her crazy
um well the thing itself
that i've been doing is i guess just
uh like potentially or starting
small little fights without knowing it
um
it's kind of hard to pinpoint um
can i just give my example yeah
sure so i wanted to leave for a movie at
a certain time we were hanging out with
my family and so everyone was
leaving a little bit later than we had
planned
uh five to ten minutes later when
everyone was getting ready to leave she
wanted to run back in and look for a
sweater she was going to be cold which
would have made us even later i was a
little annoyed and told her about it so
we discussed
we tried to figure out whether i was
wrong for rushing her when we were
already late or whether she was wrong
potentially making us slightly later
while we resolved that part of the
argument fairly quickly we then started
talking about why we miscommunicated
she felt i wasn't listening to her i
felt she wasn't listening to me and so i
got frustrated and raised my voice which
i rarely do
after that discussion ends we were both
left you know kind of hurt and feeling
like man we never used to fight like
this there was no true resolution you
know she was upset because i didn't
handle the situation perfectly
i'm upset because i didn't handle the
situation perfectly and she was hurt by
it
and so something incredibly
inconsequential about
whether we were going to be late for a
movie which
by the way we had planned to leave so
early that we were going to catch the
previews before the previews you know
like we weren't even going to be late to
the movie that didn't matter at all then
why'd you start a fight
i wasn't trying to i just that's not
what i asked it's not what i asked why'd
you start a fight
i brought it up because there is a
pattern of
my wife
making us slightly late for things or
leaving slightly later than
i would like to and so that's the only
reason i brought it up but my intention
was never to hold on a second hold on a
second okay hold on a second
this has nothing to do with the time
of course this has to do with power
and
the way you use words
um
i didn't do it perfectly
or she's gotta have
it's
very much like talking to an annoyed
parent
okay
and
there's something about her that you
married
i mean let me just ask you is she a
capable adult
yes she's incredibly does she have a job
she does does she do well at the job or
is she always getting in trouble about
the job you see what i'm saying like she
she excels she's incredible so what is
it about her that you feel the need to
parent her
or to make her her 2.0 or to improve
some things
i really don't think i feel that need dr
john but that's what you do
right
so where's that coming from
it's
my desire to
i guess fix problems as i see them
within the relationship and if i'm the
one that sees the problem i i think oh i
i need to take the step to bring it up
so we can address it so we can resolve
it so we can move on okay so let's let's
let's take that exact thing
when you want to fix a problem
you look externally towards the problem
right and the problem is her and her
timeliness
and by the way
this is a super common first year second
year marriage thing so i want you to
think y'all are crazy your marriage is
over it's none of that
right it is going to take you not being
arrogant and you being taking a knee
okay here's what i mean
you want to go to fix a problem
and then she is the problem because
she's late
and she repeatedly makes you slightly
late
that's not the problem
the problem is either you like being in
control
the problem is like you like the
appearance of
we are all we have it together and so
we're always on time
another one is this
i was always late to church always
always
and my wife would say let's go let's go
and i was like and finally one day she
said this
she said john
i feel completely exposed when i walk
into our small little church and
everyone turns to see who's walking in
late
i feel exposed and embarrassed and i
don't like everybody looking at me
and when you're late you forced me into
a position
of this
so the problem was her
and she was saying i'm addressing this
now so i'm gonna start taking my own car
without you
or
you can be a part you see what i'm
saying and i have not been late since
because i'll be damned if i'm gonna
embarrass my wife see what i'm saying
and so you
ending up late ending up late ending up
late is not about ending up late
it's about you having the courage to
tell your wife
hey when we're late to things
i feel fill in the blank
that's making the problem about you not
about her she is not up something you
can fix like an engine
that's why i'm using language like
trying to make her 2.0 like upgrade
version of herself
you can't fix her
you can communicate and say hey this is
how this makes me feel and she can say
hey when i'm gonna be cold
i'd rather be three minutes late than
cold for two hours
right right
that is different than well you did this
right so she's got some culpability here
too
also it probably uh
well i just say my when i found out that
i've been doing something for a year or
two years or 10 years that's frustrating
or annoying
i felt deceived i felt like my wife
should have told me that
and then i had to ask have i created an
unsafe environment in this home where
you can't even tell me that that you
don't like it where i put my shoes
like is that where we are and then my
wife had to take ownership and say no i
needed to tell you that and so now it's
right away
you see what i'm saying so it's both in
so as when i said maybe
um
i think there's a
fairness
hey you're getting onto me about this
and this has been happening for two or
three weeks not seven months because now
it's past the thing and now we feel like
we've been deceived but you see what i'm
getting at all these none of these
fights have anything to do with fights
has to do with with someone's got to be
right and someone's got to be wrong and
what i would tell you is and you've
probably heard this marriage advice
before you can choose to be right or you
can choose to be wrong or you can choose
to be married
right
anytime if you're right and she's wrong
you both lose
and vice versa
right
and i would tell you that the moment
that you're three minutes late is the
absolute worst time ever to have that
conversation
because it's instantly emotional she's
already feeling upset embarrassed rushed
whatever you're feeling mad and so it's
never going to be a productive
conversation it's going to be a
conversation about emotions not about
how do we how do we make some changes
and grow and heal here
see what i'm saying
i do i do
i i think
my question is
moving forward
is there something i should maybe keep
in mind
when little things like this pop up
in order to avoid
i don't know me creating an issue
i i am like i don't like to lose right
so i know that i don't like to lose
arguments
but then never ever ever have one
because that attitude will destroy your
marriage it will end it right
end it right so don't have them
right
and
my wife and i
love
to have these types of discussions is
part of our problem
there like i then it's just about
context so it's like once a week my wife
and i have our calendar budget meeting
and
that's that's when we talk about these
things because it's a rather unemotional
time it's like 8 o'clock on a sunday or
something like that like it's it's an
unemotional time
and we're just it's a very nuts and
bolts hey by the way
last week you said you were going to be
here at wednesday and you were going to
take care of dinner you didn't
this is going to be the whole every
wednesday for the rest of semester
here's what dinner looks like and i'll
be like yeah i totally screwed that up
or i'll say oh why don't you tell me and
we had that discussion then we move on
but it's not a who's going to win this
and you should have told no why why
would i fight i'm not going to fight i'm
not going to fight there's no reason to
fight
right
and again i'm being facetious
occasionally there's a reason to but
they're so rare man so rare you know
what i mean though
right i i think we both
know i mean my wife and i both know that
like
the things that we're fighting over
don't matter then stop
like you're overthinking it man stop
like when she's three minutes late why
do you have to have that conversation
right then why
i guess i don't have to yeah yeah
look at this guy dude you're gonna be
married a long time
that's the plan yes
so don't have a conversation until later
until everybody's chill
maybe keep a small little thing on your
phone or a little note to yourself
or if it's still not that big of a deal
an hour later than ta-da that's wisdom
but don't feel like you got to go to war
over everything man
and especially
if you have the thought i need to fix
this
or
anytime you think that how about this
anytime you think the thought if she
would just
do not say anything keep that to
yourself
right because that's not a statement
that's not a thought pattern that's not
an emotion that's going towards solving
a problem that's a that's a trajectory
towards victory
and i'll say it again if y'all get into
an argument with the objective that one
of us has to be right one of us has to
be wrong you will both lose a hundred
percent of those arguments
right that makes sense
and
you kind of this is back from earlier
you kind of kind of hinted around it a
little bit
never raise your voice
don't yell don't be that guy
you're right okay that's that's not
typically
what i do i was just frustrated and that
was a moment of weakness that's that's
fair completely agree but when you get
frustrated yeah when you get frustrated
say hey i'm gonna take a break for a
second i seen take a break
and that that's wisdom and restraint and
adult responsibility right it's just
being a grown-up
but here's so if i'm you here's what i
do right now i would take my life out to
dinner
okay and i would tell her i'm sorry
i'm trying to find my place here i want
to be a great husband i want to have
this presentation of our family we're
always on time and everything's always
neatly pressed and
where we looked apart and do the part
and i want to do so good
and what i ended up doing is starting a
lot of fights
and a lot of well if you would's and if
this woods and whatever and i'm sorry
i'm not gonna fight you anymore
i would like to set up like a recurring
once a week where we get coffee together
my wife and i we used to i said we'd do
a budget meetings now we started doing
two mile i mean two hour
uh walks in the morning on saturday
mornings we leave the kids they're old
enough now we just head off into we head
off on these long walks they're
fantastic
but we talk about everything man i get
animated and i can be like ah cause i'm
a lot right
i can do all those things but they're
not threatening we're on the same side
as we're walking like we're facing the
same direction together
it just changes the whole tenor so we're
still talking with some communications
but i'm just not gonna fight
so here's a good example um when she
goes to bed she doesn't let the dogs in
and i gotta let take the dogs and take
them down the set of stairs into the
basement where they stay and
at 11 o'clock at night when i'm getting
home from something and i'm tired and
the dogs are still up that is not the
time to have that conversation
at nine o'clock when i look into our
bedroom and she's already um
reading and that's not the time to have
that conversation
it's just not
when we're going for our walks on sunday
mornings or i mean on saturday mornings
or having our budget meetings but i can
say hey in the evenings it would be a
make up it's be a big deal for me if you
would go and put the dogs away when you
go ahead and
when you turn the lights off and do x y
and z
see how different of a conversation that
is and she could say by the way you
don't do anything how about you get the
dogs and i'd say all right that's well
done and then it's my job i don't have
to fight about anymore see how much how
simpler that is
yes i do okay
um does she love you
she does yes a lot
yes can you just can you rest in that
yes i think i can
can i tell you this it took me like 20
20 years that's not true probably 16 17
years to figure out how to do that
so this isn't something you can do over
time
she loves you man you're anchored in and
you're good
what we're going for here is peace is
that fair
no sir i appreciate it thank you very
much dude i appreciate you calling
um
yeah i've got high hopes for you all i
would love to see a dinner
where you
just say sorry
don't bring up anything she's brought to
the table
make it about you so i'm sorry taking a
knee and i'm gonna do better
and uh
could we set up some things
man that is changing the entire
trajectory of your family
and i'll say it for a third time this
one call
to all the couples listening if you get
in a fight with a purpose to win
i'll show him she needs to i'll tell her
one of you will win and one of you will
lose and you will both lose
every single time